which popular teenage mutant ninja
turtles character actually came from a
comic of their own and which well-known
sitcom creator wrote the show's iconic
theme song keep watching to find out you
really think that'll get his attention
you'll see just act like you're trying
to break open the candy machine
with pleasure today the teenage mutant
ninja turtles are such a part of pop
culture that you don't think twice about
how ridiculous the concept is but in the
beginning the bizarre concept of
slow-moving reptiles fighting crime was
more obviously absurd creators kevin
eastman and peter laird pulled from
three different popular comics of the
80s to come up with a new concept marvel
comics as daredevil for the gritty ninja
elements new mutants for the teenage
mutant thing and dave sims cerebus for
the animal aspect in fact it's almost
canonical that the truck that almost hit
young matt murdock is the same one that
knocked a bunch of turtles and ooze into
the sewers that fateful day in new york
city the result as far as the comics
were concerned was the send-up of the
era's most popular genres when it comes
to naming things the parody becomes even
clearer daredevils and ninjas they
became the foot clan and daredevil's own
sensei stick became the turtle sensei
splinter this unserious element is one
reason why the show's main villain has
the not so threatening name of shredder
part doctor doom part kingpin the
shredder is a villainous mastermind as
adept at fighting as he is at scheming
what do you know of the shredder we've
sworn to terminate the shredder to
avenge master yoshi terminate with
extreme prejudice that reputation
however doesn't even come close to
excusing his ridiculous name in a world
where turtles can be named after famous
renaissance artists naming a villain
after an office supply is a strange
choice with such a silly name this is
one bad guy who really set himself up
for a lifetime of humiliating failure
maybe the most bizarre thing about the
shredder is that he has a perfectly fine
real name that he could use instead of
his ridiculous alter ego your hairy
little friend knows me as
oroko saki but you may call me
the shredder a kitchen utensil action
cartoons have to ride a fine line
between showing the cool fight scenes
that fans want while keeping everything
more or less child-friendly in the eyes
of broadcast standards and practices
bsnp is a department at each television
network that's tasked with making sure
that content abides by their larger
standards in the case of teenage mutant
ninja turtles that created a bit of a
pickle for the creators both raphael and
leonardo used stabbing weapons which
meant that their fight scenes would have
to stay away from them using their
signature weapons on their opponents the
elegant solution was to keep the foot
soldier character designs that laird and
eastman had created but replaced the
ninjas themselves with ninja robots by
reestablishing that the turtles were
smashing robots and not slicing people
in half the cartoon was able to stay
surprisingly accurate to the ninja
action featured in the comics
[Music]
check those dudes out dudes nuts they're
robots robots
to make things even more complicated
viewers in the uk weren't allowed to see
nunchucks in a kid's cartoon at the time
resulting in heavy edits on
michelangelo's scenes the overall
censorship was extreme enough that the
entire theme song had to be changed
instead calling them teenage mutant hero
turtles
as much of the show was censored for
perceived violence they sure seemed to
miss just how horrifying the various
characters journeys could become
all i like is a body
a body which you have failed to provide
for me
the cartoon delighted in constant
mutations for teenage mutant ninja
turtles human characters with baxter
stockman's gruesome transformation into
a flyman easily ranking among the worst
even besides the cronenberg-esque
transformation of stockman there were
dozens of mutants and transformations
almost always accompanied by the
person's horror at what their formerly
human bodies have turned into
he's so cute
deeply rooted body horror is a bit of a
heady subject for a saturday morning
cartoon but maybe not an uncommon theme
after all and that's without considering
the turtle's own body dysmorphia after
all we're talking about humanoid turtles
that are also teenagers talk about weird
hormones leonardo
michelangelo it's me
donatello
raphael
the turtle's names have become as iconic
as the signature weapons they wield but
the deeper meaning behind them is
actually pretty shallow the turtles are
named after master splinter's favorite
renaissance artists but the names
themselves don't actually reflect any of
the turtle's personalities michelangelo
the renaissance painter was known for
the sistine chapel michelangelo the
ninja turtle is known for being a party
dude beyond that if you were to name the
four greatest painters of the
renaissance butticelli would arguably
edge out donatello butticelli after all
is known for the birth of venus which
defines the popular conception of
renaissance art to this day donatello
was much better known for being a
sculptor rather than a painter like his
turtle named contemporaries which is
probably why venus de milo a female
ninja turtle was introduced in 1997's
live action ninja turtles the next
mutation
we are a thousand miles below the
surface of the earth do you realize how
hard it is to get a decent snack down
here well the original ninja turtles
animated series is known for being
fairly kid-friendly the last few seasons
were so dark that they almost seemed
like an entirely different show besides
the new villain lord dreg the turtles
find themselves mutated into new forms
the channel 6 building is blown up and
the sky literally turns red a detail
that led fans to refer to the final
three seasons of the show as the red sky
seasons the show's pivot to darker
episodes and a more classically alien
looking villain seemed to be a gambit to
compete with power rangers which had
started to siphon off the young fan base
for tmnt or at least that was the fan
explanation for the changes regardless
it wasn't able to overcome its declining
ratings and the show ended at season 10
with the tone miles removed from the
relatively light antics of season 1
episode 1
[Music]
you fight without honor assassin
the turtles had plenty of allies human
mutant and robot alike one of the most
memorable however was the samurai rabbit
miyamoto usagi or as the cartoon
referred to him usagi yujimbo as comics
aficionados are no doubt already aware
usagi is actually the lead of another
beloved long-running black and white
comic about anthromorphic animals titled
you guessed it usagi yujimbo well
talking pigs and rabbits
i find that a little hard to swallow the
thematic overlap between usagi yujimbo
and teenage mutant ninja turtles is
obvious at first glance to their credit
the turtles haven't been shy about
embracing the similarities between the
two universes both of which were
launched in 1984. in fact the characters
have had crossovers in nearly every tmnt
iteration since the beginning in the
cartoon usagi makes an appearance in two
episodes usagi yujimbo and usagi comes
home which features him visiting the
turtles dimension and getting embroiled
in samurai hijinks even got a couple of
action figures in the original toy line
if there's one thing that every fan of
the teenage mutant ninja turtles knows
and loves it's the theme song it's a
relentlessly catchy tune played over
colorful opening credits that showcase
some great animation while lyrically
highlighting the turtle's respective
personalities to put it simply the song
is a hit the awesomeness of the teenage
mutant ninja turtles theme song really
shouldn't surprise anyone considering
who co-wrote it proven hitmaker chuck
laurie the creator of two and a half men
and the big bang theory and even though
he's since gone on to massive success as
a sitcom king lori is still proud of his
old songs longevity telling indiewire we
wrote it in an afternoon and we recorded
it in an evening and it's still alive
how cool is that and teenage mutant
ninja turtles
heroes in a half shell turtle power
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite childhood cartoons are
coming soon subscribe to our youtube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Applause]
[Music]